[Music]
to the break room Our Daily Show that
keeps you updated on all the nerdy news
you need to know uh we're thrilled to
have you here today coming up on today's
show Agatha's coven grows we have some
Loki concept art iron heart is ironic
coming okay that one didn't work I
didn't write that no no that was me
freestyling and that's why you don't
freestyle uh we discussed the original
plot to wakanda Forever it's not going
to be what you think uh and uh no
apologies to and or we do our Andor
predictions yeah uh with it astrologies
for and organs we're doing some
predicting yes uh with me today in a
slightly different order than they often
are we've got Brandon Barrett oh hello
to be here uh Tommy bechtold over there
this
is the final
Four Dragon Ball Z yeah
and uh Jessica Clements over on this
side of the table hi
yes very nice I might take him down I
don't know how I feel about it no they
look great take one down leave one up
and we'll let the chat decide the rest
uh thank you to everybody who's already
in the chat blowing it up uh and the
super chats uh coming in for every 100
we make today in super chats we were
thinking uh with Halloween in the rear
view a couple days ago
um we were going to review some rejected
yes Halloween let me let me specify
because this was this was my local
grocery stores I call it the brodega uh
uh it's just a collection of bros
getting down sometimes there's loose
soups every once in a while someone
brings in Mom's spaghetti anyway these
are what was left in the candy aisle I'm
not saying they were rejected I know
some of these are candies famous in
other cultures we're not roasting these
candies we're simply saying at my local
brodega this is what was available there
was one Snickers bar but it was cut wide
open and there was a there was a little
Post-It note that said it's gonna be
yummy you should eat it so so this
literally says assorted candies and
isn't a language I'm not even sure which
language it is yeah I think that one's
called
[Applause]
um so again when we hit a certain
Redemption we will try out these candies
we'll give it a live impromptu review of
them this looks like it's just hard
candy but again the language barrier
here we don't know what we're getting
into green of course we all think is
sour apple but what if it's cucumber
cucumber I like the emphasis you put on
those salables
um hey let's do some headlines oh baby
yeah
[Applause]
great uh first headline here uh Agatha
Covenant of chaos has been casting
several people a notably Aubry Plaza of
uh Parks and Rec yeah uh great credits
White Lotus white load oh the current
season of White Lotus that's right it
goes west Olson yeah Mike and Dave need
wedding dates
funny people I think was the first thing
I saw in funny people mystery team a
very old UCB comedy oh very good um and
my dreams in some nights that's not
dirty yeah
oh that's right she was uh the love
interest in Legion yeah um so rumors
have her playing the villain of Agatha
Covenant of chaos and that's interesting
we were there is some speculation it
could be a gender bent version of
Nicholas scratch
Nicholas scratch I believe in the comics
is uh is basically the devil yeah again
the son of Agatha yeah
Nick scratch was like Old Scratch is
like a a folklore name for the devil the
devil goes by many names I wake up every
morning with an Old Scratch
um some other uh coming to chaos has
been in the news a little bit lately as
we're getting some more stuff coming out
about it uh also cast Ali on and there
she is
um she's been in a ton of stuff
including Orange is the New Black and
um that raising Dion or Dion Netflix
series I don't know how to pronounce it
also a little fun fact about her that is
uh William Harper Jackson's girlfriend
in real life
out oh so no it's William Jackson Harper
right I always flip those two Somewhere
Out There William Harper Jackson was so
excited I know he sounds like a
president William Jennings Brian yeah
and on Maria Jefferson Maria dizzia has
also been cast who um has worked in a
ton he looks very familiar yeah she was
also in um Orange is the New Black and
she's been a million movies and stuff oh
is there a common cat I wonder if we can
do this a lot of times if you see people
show up from the same shows it's because
they have a common casting director like
weirdly I think the True Blood casting
directors cast this is us so there was
something frequently True Blood actors
on This Is Us yeah no hardcore sex
HBO famously they used the same people
all the time there's like same guys in
The Wire are in like other yeah Chris
Bauer has been in every single HVAC and
the bunk character from The Wire was on
Treme anyway
um yeah you're saying that our reposit
is going to play the villain I want
Agatha to be the villain well she's
gonna come back and then she'll be the
villain okay I think right now she's
just making cookies let our villains be
villains stop making the villains be
nice that's interesting but we've also
not only it's not just the marvelous
series but like in general rarely do you
make the title or the lead character the
bad person in a show we've never had
that in a Marvel Series so far right
kind of like Loki
what if uh what if Agatha what is Agatha
that's not a villain persevering
speaking of Loki we got some Loki
concept art uh revealing the show's
original ending
oh there it is
bottom row Center that just looks like
Timothy it does look like him those do
look like some chalamet looks Yeah Yeah
from upcoming red carpets
um oh that that's a that's an alternate
uh that's a uh
season two is a very what a game very
good um but yeah
everyone do a shallow man pressure Loki
mate shut up
uh I guess this art was from when they
weren't planning to do a second season
of the show and they were going to kind
of like more wrap up the full story yeah
yeah the guy who drew these uh they put
out a book recently with a lot of the
concept art uh and the uh the artist who
worked on these the way he talked about
it it was clear that like oh the
original when there wasn't going to be a
season two and the show was gonna end
like Loki was going to be at like a
place of peace and have changed and all
of these were to reflect his like easy
going like relaxed attitude uh you know
he's gonna go do his own thing now be
off in his own realm so I I don't know
when the decision to give that show a
second season was obviously before they
filmed the whole ending they did film uh
but it is interesting to think that like
Loki's the only show where they were
like immediately like oh yeah season two
boom everything else they've been very
slow playing yeah or spin-offs yeah even
Hawkeye becomes echo or whatever and you
know by all accounts it was a huge hit
yeah for Disney plus right as was one
division but they had to know because I
think like the Agatha announcement came
after you know there's nothing in the
show that guarantees you like a spin-off
for Agatha right yeah she locks her way
but that's just marvel putting a
character on Ice much like Abomination
but until they need them again right uh
but I don't know at what point during
the development of Loki they were like
we got to give the show a season two
it's gonna be a hit it was even in the
writer's room maybe it was before the
show even kind of started and they were
like this is too good we have too much
story to tell speaking of stories to
tell and Disney plus Series ironheart
has wrapped filming uh we know this
because there's been Twitter posts from
uh some different cast and crew members
uh and we've been kind of following on
social uh different you know you get an
image of an Anthony Ramos as the the
hood good and different kind of things
around that series but we're super
excited for that that is we talked about
this yesterday
what is the order of the next Disney
plus series is there it is thank you
John Secret in Beijing and then Echo and
then Iron Heart well Loki season two
okay Greg coogler said that it was
either him or Nate more said that
ironheart is a direct uh follow-up to
Black Panther we're kind of forever
right that was a headline from yesterday
a headline I put in the script but was
not here to deliver uh you're trying to
collect it I was stuck in the machine I
was stuck I'm saying I was stuck in the
machine at that point before I was freed
for mandatory fun I don't know if you
guys noticed I was pleading for you guys
to rescue me oh did you get sucked into
your computer and you were writing the
headlines right away I was trying to
communicate with you guys through the
headlines yesterday and you ignored me
wow you showed up anyways so you got it
because I feed myself a rat ran across
my keys so really so really the lesson
there was you had to power all along
that was the Arc of yourself
I am great nothing to change here all
right final form
tell me uh real quick we want to shout
out uh some folks that help us bring
this show to you you know we as as fans
as new rockstars employees we go to a
lot of conventions we love getting swag
that's one of the best parts about going
to a convention but you know what I'm
gonna be honest with you a lot of Swag
sucks I said it uh it's cheap you know
if it's a shirt it doesn't fit right uh
it falls apart whatever it definitely
doesn't make you want to support the
business that is handing out that swag
but our friends it Lands End Business
are here to end the scourge of bad swag
bad swag hashtag
what do we say crap crab swag I know I
cleaned it up a little bit but crab swag
has a better ring to it uh Hey Lands End
Business you can get fully customized
clothes accessories promotional products
featuring your logo and colors and it's
elevated by Decades of experience that
they have at Land's End so your logo and
Vivid colors are t-shirts outerwear hats
mugs water bottles all of that hundreds
of products perfect for any trade show
event or holiday gift here's another
thing was your company have a work
uniform maybe you're a plumber maybe you
work at a bakery maybe uh whatever maybe
even just got a nice Polo that everybody
rocks there at your place of work maybe
you have a business in Southwest Florida
where you go around killing iguanas
maybe you're an invasive species is that
you no is that what you did it's my
dream job maybe a afternoon live
lives we use a sensible vest yes
absolutely with a break room logo nice
fleece anyone hearing that out there
yeah yeah wouldn't it be fun if we all
do this uh uh landsat best is uh they
make awesome uniforms in premium Fabrics
they're none of this itchy uh you know
you feel gross wearing the uniform see
why thousands of companies count on
Lands End Business go to business dot
lands end.com slash podcast and use
promo code podcast for 25 off your first
product if that's too much of a mouthful
the link is on screen and in the
description of this video that's
business.landsend.com podcast use promo
code podcast for 24 25 off your first
product uh thank you to them for helping
us and I just want to mention uh this is
a pretty exciting announcement crab swag
and I are dropping an album
uh which will be available on our
streaming platform
it's going to be on gagara starting
Monday morning at midnight until 2 A.M
you can get the dump for free I feel
like the dump is a hip-hop
right you know it's like a real funny
thing too many hot dogs on the pier got
a dude
yeah sometimes you just gotta go right
off the pier straight into the manatees
uh let's go let's move on some fresh
water okay freshwater
pearly yeah they live in uh Rivers they
can handle a little bit of brackish
water but they prefer fresh water I am
17 years old and that's the first time
I've heard that yeah or how old I am 17
years younger everybody on this
everybody on this panel under 23. yeah
Pirates used to think the amenities were
well those were the mermaids that's how
hard up they were for a little action on
the ocean you see the hot chicken
they're all like hey this is an area
before contact lenses okay you know what
I mean you guys see a striped Manatee
with whiskers the thing that has a a sea
creature
beautiful mermaid I've ever seen
the best part about a mermaid their
nipples are in their armpits or their
manatees you just have mermaids
so stop adding me when you see me
sucking on those armpits
Tommy the dog two strikes two strikes
let's turn off the pier straight off the
pier to a manatee's armpit to dump the
Donk
all right should we talk about uh
yeah let's talk about real oh sorry but
I sorry I just set you up but I want to
cut you off hey everybody welcome back
my dude we are going to be watching
Jessica's already seen what kind of
forever she got to go to one of the
premieres don't say anything uh she's
not gonna spoil it uh but the rest of us
have not seen the movie yet we're gonna
see it as a staff next Thursday
uh and then we are gonna do some very
special stuff around that next Thursday
next week okay so uh if you haven't
already bought tickets buy yourself a
ticket so you can see it uh right when
it comes out and then you can keep up
with all the great content on new
rockstars surrounding uh what kind of
forever also I really want to eat one of
these so you guys better be centered in
the Super Chat okay
trash bag did set on a Super Chat saying
Merry Christmas Breakers wow already
Christmas for you I agree All I Want For
Christmas is more Super chats to say
Merry Christmas Perry Clement says so
glad to tune in live we're glad you're
here Perry Clemens no relation no
relationship some relationship oh okay
okay thank you Jessica is so uh what's
the right not candid
um secretive about Perry Clemens I think
it might actually be a real relative
because every time we ask her and we
have asked her for she's like no maybe
some I think it's
I think it's I think it's I mean it's
not the most common last name no it is
Clemens Clarence Clemens from E Street
Band uh because we're related oh you are
related to that Clemens okay Clemens
wasn't he the old man that runs the
daily uh planet and that's Perry white
uh
wow wow wow I'm stupid I'm so I can't
wait okay uh okay so uh we'll come to
forever right uh obviously the movie had
to change a lot and from its original
Inception to where it is now with the
passing of Chadwick Boseman and Ryan
Cooler's been doing some interviews
recently kind of talking about the what
the original wakanda forever was going
to look like uh if you remember the
first black panther film came out in
2018
uh and then we originally saw Black
Panther in Civil War right it kind of
gets an introduction there we see the
full film of 2018 that Infinity War
happened and but right after even like
during the making of uh the original
black panther film Ryan coogler was
already thinking about what's next like
what he would want to do next right uh
because when he was brought in to Marvel
to like do this film he talks to he's
been doing some interviews recently uh
and there's a great podcast out right
now uh you can find it on Spotify or
whatever it's like the wakanda forever
like official podcasts Tallahassee coach
is like interviewing Ryan coogler in it
it's really good I recommend it it's
great it's very interesting uh and Ryan
cougar was like very honest in it uh
about his feelings that everything had
to change because you know he had no
idea Chadwick was sick like most people
did not he's working on this he even
says like he sent he finished the script
like right before Bozeman had passed and
like sent him the script before he sent
it to Marvel for like final notes and
stuff he really credits Chadwick for
being there because when he was brought
in to be Black Panther in Civil War
right uh cougar talks about how like
he's like 10th build in that movie you
know what I mean it's got Robert Downey
Jr and Chris Evans and everyone else and
it was like like Chadwick and the
producer Nate Moore who's also a
producer on Black Panther and black
panther with kind of forever they were
like the Star Wars of this t'challa
character right so he comes in they make
the move they make the first black
panther and what he's saying about the
original draft of the Black Panther
wakanda forever uh was that it was very
similar to the movie we have now uh
tonally he said it was gonna always be a
movie about grief uh because what his
vision was originally was that like the
story was unfolding that at the end of
Black Panther and the post-credits scene
you know t'challa goes to like the U.N
and he's like we're gonna open up
wakanda here we are we have all this
technology we're walking to the world
then the events of infinity War happen
and t'challa dust right and he's gone
for five years so his original sequel
was gonna be about him coming back to
wakanda after being blipped for five
years and him
dealing with that having feel like he
let his people down he wasn't there for
them after he
showed the world where they were and was
then like gone and how they dealt with
that and they lost like you know a ton
of people there not to mention the fact
that Infinity War the big battle is
right there in what kind of yeah tons of
people die even before there's a lot of
drama there yeah he's the one that lets
Vision come in with an infinity stone
instead of being like no get the hell
out of here go anywhere else he's like
no come in we'll defend it and he brings
a lot of stuff there so this story was
going to be a same tone this kind of
grief it was going to be like a real
deep dive onto Charlie the character uh
and unfortunately a lot of that had to
change obviously but that's I think
that's the most fascinating thing as
cougar saying that like the tone of the
movie was going to be the same yeah it
was always going to be this this kind of
like sad look at grief uh and what it
means for characters and how they grow
and how they move and one thing like
he's talked about in other interviews
leading up to what kind of forever is
that like you know two huge themes of
this movie are like leadership and what
it's like to lead a people right like
that's uh name Namor and uh t'challa
both are both like the heroes of the
people but also like their leaders their
kings their presidents their whatever
their gods
um and like how that weighs on a
character in a person and like what like
kind of like what leadership means to
guide a people and stuff like that it's
like you can see how like yeah obviously
if if Chadwick had not passed that that
would have still been the theme and it
is currently the theme as well right
yeah and this movie was always gonna
have Neymar in it it was always going to
be about these two different Nick Moore
was always going to do you know all
right we got to get used to the nap nah
I was talking to Eric the other day I'm
saying Nate more he's like wait Neymar
has like no Neymar
uh uh but it's always going to be about
these two countries and like how they
fit together and how they work together
uh because cougar was talking about you
know when he got hired to do by Panther
of course like Marvel sends you like
every comic right and he was always a
big fan of the character but he was like
really diving into it and he was always
like kind of like into he noticed that
like oh Neymar comes up of like
characters that black panther interacts
within the comics Neymar is like a big
one so he gets asked in one of these
interviews and he kind of denies it he
says that another interviewer was like
oh Kevin feige said that you were always
talking about Neymar uh in Atlantis he's
like I was I I don't know but he we
talked about this on the show this week
or last week that like he claimed Neymar
earlier yeah right I think that was in
the post-production of the first film
right and when you originally became
part of uh Marvel Ryan coogler uh Neymar
was still kind of Rights dependent
because I think he was connected to like
that Fantastic Four deal from Fox yeah
and like they hadn't made it so
interesting they hadn't made an Aquaman
movie yet they hadn't done any of that
so he wanted to do it right uh and I
think he kind of felt like oh that sucks
that like that that uh you know Aquaman
comes out first because I think he
wanted to put anymore in the first Black
Panther movie there for the jump I think
what's so interesting is
from with everything we just learned
about what possibly was going to be the
original concept all we know really I
mean I've kind of ignored the most
recent Clips because I feel like they've
been giving us so much yeah it's
dangerous out there but the you know the
kind of the marketing up until a week
ago was like we know that wakanda is in
mourning right like we see those scenes
and then we know that Neymar shows up so
what the heck is in the rest of this
movie I mean I feel like my excitement
to watch Jessica don't tell us she's
done a great job there's been absolutely
zero spoilers I'm seeing it Monday this
coming Monday yeah see it Monday night
I'm very excited boy uh and then I'm
taking my nephews on Friday
jealous nephew Brad uh nephew I have
nephews jealous uh anyway but yeah like
we what is in the rest of this movie we
don't know I mean there's been very few
like I feel like we we know so much
about those specific themes Neymar and
the and the talocons are coming telecons
yeah and then and then that there's
gonna be this like and I think what Jay
told us what Jay Washington was on here
is like they they start right in the
morning process like the movie begins
with everyone morning to child's death
so I don't know Jessica I know you can't
say but what do we think what else is
going to be in there
yeah she just filmed a video uh with her
some of her thoughts on the film it'll
come out next week yeah is everything
Ross Doom foreign
yeah and I will say speaking of town of
Hussey Coates who's the co-host of that
like he's a Pulitzer prize-winning
writer has done novels and all kinds of
stuff but he wrote some of the great
kind of recent black panther Comics arcs
uh a lot of which have been pulled into
the films right inspired coogler
um and in a lot of those right they deal
with kind of the like metapolitical
aspect of like leadership in wakanda and
like we they gotta we got into that a
little bit in the first movie of like
you know the different tribes and like
how hard it is to kind of keep these
disparate groups of people aligned for
the greater good and yada yada right
like this is great in the comics and so
like you can see how like that would
have inspired even the hypothetical
version of this second film as well yeah
yeah that was like always very important
to him and my time has to coach in this
podcast really talks about how there
wasn't a lot of representation for
t'challa in these in in like Marvel
Comics for like a long time he talks
about as a kid how he like never saw
t'challa and he was like he would
randomly show up and when they had like
a big 25th anniversary big special he's
like not in it and like he was always so
frustrated with that and he was so
excited that Ryan coogler was going to
get to do this movie and like really
Praises him for doing such a great job
with the character and really growing it
as somebody who gave out Halloween candy
I can say that like Spider-Man was
number one as far as comic book
characters little kids dressed up as
comic book characters Black Panthers
number two
yeah absolutely producer John he just
spiked the direct
five minutes sorry it's okay when you
were talking one of the things that I
found most hi it's all family now how
are you uh one of the things I found
most interesting during that phase zero
interview was you know there's that line
in Avengers end game where they were
like oh it's an earthquake under the
ocean like we deal with it by not
dealing with it Marcus and mcfeely were
like yeah we sort of put that in it's
like a throwaway to Neymar and maybe
Marvel will do something with it but
Ryan Cooper was like well I watched this
movie as a fan and I was sort of like
nah that's not that's not anymore for me
that was like oh maybe that's like Chloe
Zhao and eternals and Tiana
I like oh that's a good news so that was
like GMI giving like a fart yeah
check out the
the official uh podcast it's it's great
it's getting free they're doing one
episode now and then they're gonna do I
think four more in January uh where
they're gonna go super in depth with
some of the other folks do you think
that will coincide with maybe its
release on streaming yeah maybe of
course you know when that comes out
we'll we'll be kind of done we'll cover
the hell out of it again we've got I
don't think we're ready to announce it
but we've got very fun plans for next
week very fun plans here on the break
room yeah
no John we love it uh some say you we're
never welcome oh my God kidding kidding
we love producer guys
uh soon
goddamn uh but speaking of things that
are welcome we want to shout out our
friends at Athletics oh yeah Brandon
you're sitting on some of that delicious
I sit on the athletic greens yeah you
take it a different way right we always
tested orally Brandon does it a
different stuff you know they don't
recommend it but you can uh what do you
do uh I nothing okay nothing I can talk
about on the internet uh we do want to
thank athletic greens I personally I'm a
big fan of their ag-1 uh it's an easy
way to get all your daily nutrition in
one easy and tasty drink every scoop of
ag-1 has 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and other good stuff you need
to take stay on top of your game if
you've ever seen me play basketball you
know I'm good at it
falls online
maybe your game is wingspan or Settler's
a guitar no it's definitely basketball
I'm so good at basketball
maybe what was your nickname uh the back
of the courts they called it the ball
uh but ag1 is one thing you can do every
single day to take great care of
yourself just like playing basketball
reclaim your health and arm your immune
immune system with convenient daily
nutrition it's just one scoop and a cup
of water every day that's it I've had a
lot of green drinks in my life that
tastes like crap this stuff is actually
pretty good yeah I don't mind it I like
it and like I take it in the morning I'm
like don't have to work out you don't
have to do anything else well I've done
the most healthy thing I could do for
myself all day it is really good and
I've been taking for months now and I do
feel like I'm sleeping a little better
hey I think I sleep a little better even
though those
young women who live above us in our
apartment are so loud what does their
gender have to do with it they just they
wear a lot of high heels are they single
are you sure they might be I don't know
no I've seen them in the laundry room
and I'm like stop walking so stop
staring at them you're married stop
walking so loud he just looks at their
feet
Agy is making me sleep better uh and to
make it easy for all of you athletic
greens is going to give you a free
one-year supply of immune supporting
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase all you have to
do is visit athleticgreens.com break
room that's athletic greens.com break
room and take ownership of your health
and pick up the ultimate daily nutrition
yes thank you guys let it greens and
then final quick shout out here yeah why
don't we give a quick shout out to the
Batman audio Adventures we want to shout
out the second season of the hit show
DC's Batman the audio Adventures which
is now out on HBO Max it's got an
awesome cast that includes Rosario
Dawson Johnny Leguizamo Bobby Moynihan
Jeff Wright and who played Jim Gordon in
the Batman is voicing the Caped Crusader
himself in this show what a glow up the
guy has one of the best voices working
in the business today he's one of the
best in the biz did he write this copy
into Jeffrey right he's a great dad and
he can throw a baseball 90 miles an hour
follows the Batman and he navigates a
crime-infested Gotham with harleen
quinzel Catwoman The Riddler and all the
other Rogues Gallery the show was
written and created by long time SNL
writer Dennis mcnicholas and he's staff
the cast with some comedy ringers like
Bobby Moynihan friend of the show Chris
Barnell Keenan Thompson
musical guests John Leguizamo Jeffrey
Wright tune in for the tale of life and
death in Gotham City the whole season
one is available to stream and season
two is out now on HBO Max a cartoon by
Robert smigiel
dream DC's Batman the audio Adventures
season two now on HBO Max it's time for
mandatory fun wow
all right mandatory fund is now canon in
Gotham City thanks to that death
connection uh before we start mandatory
fun take your little cursors put it over
the thumbs up button and like this
stream my buddies my friends my pals my
bro dagas come on now like the stream
like it all oh we just got a cute little
wink from one of our offices
on the other side of this table folks
someone called Mariah Carey because it's
fantasy time no no sweet sweet fantasy
baby
all right anyway
we uh we have admittedly been a little
lacks in celebrating our Andor fantasy
or playing our Andor fantasy predictions
League
and we're gonna get to it today because
I have gone through comedy episodes
tallied up at exact tally of the points
but first it's time for a celebration
and a coronation folks we recently
completed our She-Hulk predictions
fantasy league and we are thrilled to
announce our first member of the wall of
Champions
it's Jessica Clooney
hey
yes Jessica's photo will be placed on
the celebratory Wall of Fame at a later
date
you look at that wall you don't see me
right now but for now we have a very
special guest to present you with your
celebratory meal what a beautiful
Seafood boy
tell me what is this
we've spared no expense we've got you
one crawfish is that potato juice
one frozen corn and one uncooked potato
wow don't eat it don't touch it it's
simply a prop it's indicative of a meal
that will take place at a later date yes
yeah yeah yeah
this is the this is the pie in the
display case that they don't serve but
it's for looking at by the way anyone
around the office I've got 19 other
crawfish in the fridge uh they're
available for boiling and Toyland
and most importantly Eric's got a crown
oh and yes and Eric says all queens need
their crowns
the resident Theory Theory
upon new rock stars and Champion
theories yes
long live the queen
yeah
[Applause]
you have to stay on okay I didn't leave
yeah to Andor if we may uh please if you
will uh give us a little scrolly scroll
on that and or uh uh thank you here are
the current standings last uh Zach took
serial card last week here in 12 points
I'll explain on Instagram uh that gives
him 46 on the year Brandon took Deidre
Miro she earned 10 points giving him 46
points on the year wow I got Andor by
Nate by nature of the uh uh processing
whoever is left over I gave myself 15
points well deserved but giving me 33
points I do want to mention I am the
sole Point Giver it is completely up to
me I am in control I can have a hundred
points right now somehow I am so far
behind does it speak to a low
self-esteem
I'm the little boy in kindergarten that
gave all his crams away and had to color
with blood Jessica took mon Mothman and
only got eight points but she is still
in the lead 50 points this year
Tommy will eat this corn
ER sure why not it's corn what a
beautiful thing it's got the juice it's
got the juice I couldn't imagine you eat
it I've heard you eat it from your uh
copper to your knob or if you do oh
freak off from my corn chewers from a
boost viewer I love corn now like we are
doing and or a little bit different now
we're trying we're toying with the
process I'm in the lab mixing up
different ingredients creating a fantasy
that is so sweet that is so rewarding to
the fans so this now how we're doing it
now is that each one of the big four and
Eric will be here to help all right
they're gonna we're gonna argue a
character and how many points we think
they deserve kind of a bidding process
then Eric and I will decide for these
three gibrones what they get and then I
will argue and and the four of you will
decide how many points I get now we all
previously should have selected a
character we're going to be arguing on
their behalf and why they deserve many
points we're going to keep this to
around a minute you get about a minute
to argue your case Okay Brandon you want
to go first yeah I do do we have the
clots John
do we have the minute clock let's put it
up there okay
okay she was proven right this week all
right her plans are coming to fruition
she's finding these Rebels she's
narrowing down the axis which is a great
name for him what a good name love that
name uh uh she deals with a crazy psycho
stalker who follows her to work grabs
her without consent and she tells him
hey buddy you better back off or I'm
gonna throw you in a cell and no one's
ever gonna see you again okay she's got
Men at Work who don't believe her but
she's coming up roses all the time and
plus she's doing out a little enhanced
interrogation yeah well technically Dr
Gorsuch is hey hey he's following orders
and she's throwing out those Uber
drivers
impressive
she's even working remotely okay she
doesn't have time to go do the
interrogation of person she'll do it
over the phone that's totally fine she I
deserve 15 points because Deidre Miro is
holding it down and she's going to be
proven right the rebels are bad the Jedi
are bad long live the empire
wow I gotta say I know this is my
decision and my decision alone but Eric
I I don't think he missed a note on that
I don't think so he knows the way to uh
a work from home smart is by making a
case for this maybe could have been an
email thank you thank you this
interrogation could have been I have to
say I feel like you you Miro for me was
he was the MVP uh very evil MVP of that
episode a great episode uh I have no
choice but to Grant full points to that
full point what's full point okay this
is fair which is a fair ask who would
like to go next can I can I go next uh
if you don't mind okay
um my character that I'm going for who
won the episode Kino Indie circus he's
uh prison boss character a program on
program on uh feed flat on program uh
here's why Kino is everything that is
great about Andor okay first off Eight
Episodes in and you drop super famous
person Andy circus in as a side roll
okay that's the kind of show this is
famous
hey director of one of the Jungle Book
movies
Andy sergius no but he wasn't in any of
the promo for the show right we didn't
know they slipped him in and uh and you
think oh is it just one episode uh Cameo
no he's gonna have a huge part because
again he's everything that's great about
Andor he is the resistance building
right he was he was do your job dude I
got I got 200 shifts left quick quit
don't make a fuss don't make a fuss but
we see over the course of two episodes
the events turned the hope get lost
right so that he is he becomes a rebel
right in front of our eyes right and
that final line of of this week's
episode
how many how many guards on each level
12.
never more than 12. what a way to end
Kino's my dude yes oh I like it how many
points you're asking for uh 60.
I think to reward Kino on the level of
Miro is disingenuous hey you know what
it should be never less than 12. I think
he's right I'm gonna give you 12. okay
wonderful wonderful everyone my princess
is satisfying I'm on that keto diet
yeah we decided that me and Voss were
gonna team up
we said that we I genuinely am not
making things up we said that today
we're switching teams
so boss go ahead get them okay uh my
pick for who deserves to win after this
episode uh I think it's gonna have to be
our man Cyril card
zero card who perfectly shuts down his
mom with that sass then she doesn't even
hear it because What's the title of this
episode nobody's listening he slurps his
cereal like the like a man who knows how
to clap back at his mama but she gives
them more cereal she does that's that
that's how you win in today's America
2022 the year of Our Lord this is how
you get a you get ahead you get fired
from your job you use nepotism to get a
new job you grab a Woman by her arm and
you let your mom pour you cereal this
guy's going to be Emperor Palpatine's
like 30 command by the end of this also
classic 90s mom move of like serial
counts as a meal and I'm gonna guilt you
about the fact that I provided that like
you don't understand I give you two
meals a day also real quick he says I
have ways of knowing you're in my
private box whatever his ways of knowing
yeah it's a little thin strip of taste
yeah
okay uh also he said I sense it this is
our man might be Force sensible
okay also real quick just just
projecting forward what are the chances
we get a loveseat between him and Mira
oh I hope they already had they had
confirmed sex on this show in the first
episode
I know I was pretty surprised I wanted
Tim to die a virgin uh oh so also when
when Cyril and Mira do hook up who
chokes who I think it's a two-way all
right
[Applause]
for this uh okay oh but how many points
you think you deserve for that 15.
I have to recuse myself from this but
yeah I think we deserve 15 for that I
feel great
uh you get seven points uh I'll go last
and I'll go best I'm gonna take Andor
because you simply forgot to take him
again
I don't need a minute put put put 30
seconds on the clock speed it up speed
it up where's the graphics Department
listen to me first let's talk about hey
Andor he's got control of the team he
wins him some flavored host meat yum yum
out of the bowl Coco meat hoes Coco meat
hoes call back to Wookie leaks all right
promise sorry uh so so okay he gets the
Coco host me Yum Yum Yum he's he's
helping old men out I thought you only
needed 30 seconds no I listen I got
distracted because I started thinking
about Coco husband again yeah the clock
just started they're making Death Star
chassis up in this keep an old Olaf
great what happens when they when they
go against Pandora Olaf the snowman from
Frozen has a stroke he goes
guys Olaf dead and or live get City
circus on his side pull up dead end or
Alive get ready circus on his side
that's all I need I want 20 points well
you get only ten uh that's not how it
works wow Revenge points don't work that
was right and again we say this all the
time and or so good if you haven't been
watching it that's okay we get it watch
that show catch up uh how many even Nine
episodes we've been Nine episodes and
the next three is like it's a they do
like kind of like three story three
episode story arcs roughly yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so we have uh we're gonna
finish this next Arc and I think we'll
have like a two episode Arc at the end
of this season I don't think they're
gonna take the next like three episodes
sometimes Prison Break R.I.P WikiLeaks
if you're down to stick around uh I
think we've the super chats have hit a
level no one made a decision on my
points I asked for 20. do I get that oh
oh we I thought
yeah he said no I like Jessica's 10. I'm
cutting mine in half she hears Eric
fault here's my very logical argument I
think this was actually a pretty weak
and or episode yeah he didn't do that
much he got busted moves I know I'm just
so far behind I just wanted to make them
I feel like that's more of a personal
upfront to me I agree I think people
were taking it out by the way guys check
out zachieskakis.com we're doing
something great in the pant game Zach
and I have started a revolutionary khaki
company no pee stains in there you can
pee as much as you want there's no khaki
you gotta you gotta pay you gotta pay it
forward that's right what's the Tim
Robinson
it's a fake don't search zacky's
snackies it's a very different websites
so we'll give Tommy 11 points I thought
13.
but it's not okay we hit the Redemption
will you join us
so we're trying out those candies is
there a leftovers
these are what was available in my candy
yeah
again this um this red candy we're going
to close up on it here in a second uh is
not written in the English alphabet I
think that is uh uh no I told you it's
pronounced thank you thank you again to
all of our super Chatters Diana Santos
really putting us over there
thank you uh TD Jones Christian
unpronounceable well-rounded mom said
candy Time Sugar up we do this that's a
great mom and Keith swear it's a great
one green okay I'm gonna try these ones
that are also not in English
oh there is I think this is a grape on
this guy and this is definitely a great
flavored um these are jelly I thought
they were like Jolly Ranchers jelly
beans
oh actually now I've had those those
guys before those are great I grew up
with these because
I love these These are good those are
really sour but it's really good
thank you John did say Eagles 31 Bill's
28 Super Bowl 57 Fly Eagles Fly who's
that check diesel that was check diesel
ban him from the chat
you have something I want everybody you
could create that good to have you back
there body in the house
oh body okay body body body body body
body
body
shiny can I be a body if I'm not an
actual Dad yet oh oh I was thinking the
body from making a stallion but yeah
they're not bad they come in they almost
taste it like coffee oh they're huge it
tastes like a little vanilla wafer no
these are freaking huge let's see it
almost tastes like coffee question says
happy Festivus hey let's go for the rest
of us thank you for supporting us oh no
there's some holiday debate in the chat
Jamir green saying stop disrespecting
Thanksgiving the ultimate holiday Old
Bay on everything oh yeah I do like
Thanksgiving as a holiday it's secular
which I really appreciate I mean not me
only the Christian ones the history of
Thanksgiving is a little spacious and uh
you know whatever we're whitewashed and
right they dine together yes but I think
the ultimate goal of Thanksgiving is
great you know having having a dinner
inviting people to your table inviting
people to your home it's it's a it's a
holiday everyone can get by yeah yeah
it's a good friend's holiday too if
you're if maybe you live in the city
away from your family listen I've always
said my favorite Thanksgiving film is
Pocahontas uh it's factually accurate oh
my gosh GSU Eagles says unrelated to
what kind of forever but now that we
know Valhalla exists in the MCU will we
see the Warriors Three return I think
this is supposed to be like a peach
I don't think you need a Valhalla to get
the Warriors Three back in here you just
get the multiples well once they brought
up as War
[Music]
so we're so lucky bosses between us I
will literally fight you you can bite
them I keep trying to stop you it is
interesting how they kind of wrote off
the Warriors Three when it seems like
before they're gonna be a big deal they
get a lot of screens coming for um Dark
World they get a little bit of screen
time they're part of the Dark World
fighting right but then it's like Yeah
by Ragnarok they're like well lady sip
isn't even there she's not even in it
which turns out to be a smart move
because I'm in a TV show right local
yeah no she was on that Agents of Shield
when they were doing the crossover when
agents have said what you're talking
about she was on the NBC show yeah
ABC
God damn it I get what it feels like now
this is such a great this is great uh
what do they call it um perspective no
yeah perspective right now I see what
it's like to talk to me with them what
is me I you yelled at say goodbye to
this we reached them why do you feel
like you get yelled at that a lot is it
because maybe you do the problematic
activities no get out of here okay
oh God that's a crunch it's a Creed
bracket over here
there's like an apple yeah Holy One of
These shrimps no no maybe another shrimp
I think this was a cooked potato and it
was
it's been buried underground
so what happens now on the show
oh we could end yeah
um here uh again was it good well shout
out uh this is me TD Jones um there was
also a fun super chair somebody just put
some emo uh endless mic 1337. I don't
know what those emojis I think they're
candies oh that makes sense endless
might oh yeah it kind of looks like
birds from here yeah uh but we thank you
all we thank everybody for joining us
today we'll wrap up a little early today
uh we got Eric Voss in the house we want
to go party with our buddies I had talks
more
honestly imagine I think what happened
here is you screwed us and now we're
ending a little early no I think
honestly you showed up and probably made
uh too many valid points you threw us
off for a rhythm normally I always yell
interject things inappropriately
everybody real quick you missed it
yesterday Eric do you have a um MCU porn
parody title oh no pressure let's see
stop it put it down that's good it goes
great with my ag1
um I mean Ant-Man and the WASP Quan come
oh yeah Mania I like that welcome to the
game
I think that's why I'm not the girl
anyway we also would have been we also
would have accepted Ant-Man on the west
queef to Mania yeah would we have
accepted it
do you have any uh recommendations for
things to watch or read that yeah watch
the patient right now
Steve Carell was that good that was so
good yeah I've heard great things yeah I
love the American how about grabernard
like Avatar but grabernard grab an art
keep saying it there's a foreign
[Music]
yes a gorgeous wiener
oh my God we called Sigourney so
gorgeous I said Sigourney Weiner and you
said so gorgeous it's a gorgeous wiener
and the cocoa meat hose I saw my
Coachella
it's a gorgeous wiener man if you can
see them at a con and get their
autograph see them while they're alive
folks these Legends aren't going to be
around forever
oh we got other meetings we gotta get to
okay yeah we thank you all so much and
for joining us so disappointed in US
yeah hey just just wait till we get her
photo on the wall it's gonna be quite
today we'll have a whole uh crowning uh
or this was the crowning we'll have a
photo ceremony we'll have an unveiling
like when they drop a banner at a stage
yes okay thank you everybody
[Music]